moi je pense qu'il n'y aura pas de
retour à la vie normale en tout cas
d'ici 2022
tout simplement parce que nous avons des
personnels devant des personnes dans
notre entourage qui sont médecins et qui
travaille en réanimation et qui nous ont
dit que les mesures qui ont été prises
dernièrement était totalement farfelue
et et pas du tout comment dire pas du
tout adapté pour ce qui se passait en
fait donc moi je pense que oui mais
c'est une utopie total c'est juste
histoire de donner un petit peu
confiance aux français et c'est dire
allez ça va aller mais franchement mieux
se dire que 2022
un objectif déjà c'est plus probable
alors écoutez honnêtement
on est obligé d'être un peu optimiste
parce que ça fait quand même déjà un an
qu'on survit donc moi je suis taxi un
personnellement on est obligé d'espérer
en effet on voit par rapport à ce qui se
passe un petit peu en angleterre
en israël on va prendre plus
l'angleterre qui est proche de nous on
voit qu'à une amélioration donc
finalement que finalement macron le
veuille ou non on devrait avoir une une
amélioration de la ski ski à
à ce que cet été on puisse faire quelque
chose je suis pas sûr honnêtement je
suis pas sûr parce qu'on a pris beaucoup
de retard
la plupart des scientifiques disent
qu'on a six mois de retard sur israël 2
à 3 mois sur l'angleterre
donc honnêtement j'ai un peu de doute
mais mais je crois en la puissance
français je pense vraiment que ça va ça
va aller à vrai dire je le gars très peu
les infos déjà primeau et on a été en
conflit
voilà plusieurs fois donc du coup bon là
je j'attends vraiment doublement quand
ce sera la fin plutôt que de croire ce
cas ce que disent les politiques ou les
fronts politique parce que eux-mêmes ils
savent pas vains mots qu'on se sera
terminée moi j'y crois pas parce que
tout simplement
d'ici là il y aura pas suffisamment de
personnes vaccinées
je pense donc que déjà il ya un manque
de vaccins et avec tous les variants
avec qui peuvent surgir à tout moment et
je pense que voilà la vie nomade sa sas
implique l'ouverture du bar restaurant
et tout ce qui s'ensuit moi je fais un
petit peu pessimiste quoi pas du tout
compte tenu compte tenu de la suite des
événements et du cafouillage qui a
depuis un an depuis un an je vois
pourquoi cette promesse ne tiendrait
plus que jouent les autres c'est quelque
chose que vous attendez vous hu doit
s'arrêter oui depuis un moment déjà
j'ai envie d'y croire après l'animé au
final c'est dans un mois et demi donc je
pensais que depuis janvier on irait
couvert du mieux de manière très vite au
pic
donc là je vois pas comment partant de
la situation actuelle comment on
pourrait aller aussi rapidement vers le
retour à la vie normale